la bibliothèque départementale et
attributaires du dépôt légal
c'est-à-dire qu'elle reçoit tout ce qui
est imprimé est édité à la réunion et
une part très importante de ce qui est
imprimé édité à la réunion ce sont les
journaux les quotidiens les
hebdomadaires et mensuels à la
bibliothèque nous conservons de manière
vraiment systématique depuis les années
70 la presse locale mais nous avons des
collections plus anciennes par exemple
ici on a la collection du gier et qui
permet de voir la colle au jir a évolué
en termes de format en termes de nombre
de pages il est passé à la couleur dans
les années 90 pour qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui au jir que nous connaissons
plus de 1200 titres de périodiques sont
conservés dans notre bibliothèque
ce qui fait des milliers d'exemplaires
ce qui me permet de vous signaler que la
réunion est un département très
dynamique en termes de presse puisque il
ya environ 150 titres de périodiques
150 journaux qui sortent tous les ans à
la réunion alors ça va du quotidien ou
mensuelle à la brochure
trimestriels des banques par exemple
mais c'est un département qui est
reconnu comme très dynamique c'est
périodiques ses journaux et ses
magazines que nous collectons à la
bibliothèque départementale nous avons
le souci de les conserver donc pour ce
faire elles sont ces journaux sont
entreposés dans des boîtes spéciales
dans notre magasin de conservation et
ses titres sont tout à fait consultable
par le public c'est d'ailleurs une
partie de notre collection qui est la
plus consultée parce que de nombreux
réunionnais viennent rechercher tels
articles qui parlent de leur famille ou
tel évènement du jour de leur naissance
donc n'hésitez pas à venir la
bibliothèque départementale pour
consulter par exemple le journal de
votre année de naissance si vous êtes
des dans les années soixante dix à
partir des années 70